con sus reivindicaciones sobre el sahara
occidental oficialmente reconocidas las
autoridades marroquíes no tienen más que
elogios para sus aliados estadounidenses
un ojo con eso la decisión de eeuu una
gran potencia miembro permanente del
consejo de seguridad de la onu y un
actor influyente en la escena
internacional es el esperado
reconocimiento del sahara marroquí y la
soberanía de marruecos sobre todo su
territorio incluidas las provincias del
sur de licuados el reino ya controla una
gran parte del sahara occidental pero el
resto del territorio es administrado por
el frente polisario un movimiento
independentista sus representantes han
condenado la decisión de washington
trump ha decidido tomar una posición que
va en contra del derecho internacional
para derrocar la es para mí esto no es
considerado nada más que un robo
internacional internacional de la
antigua colonia española el sáhara
occidental fue anexionado por marruecos
en 1975 provocando la resistencia del
frente polisario entonces apoyado por
argelia en 1990
no entró en vigor una tregua y naciones
unidas convocó un referendo sobre el
futuro del territorio pero las
propuestas de independencia fueron
duramente rechazadas por marruecos
proponiendo conceder autonomía a la
región pero manteniéndola bajo su
control sin embargo el largo cese el
fuego se rompió el mes pasado cuando
marruecos lanzó una operación militar en
la zona de amortiguación acusando al
polisario de bloquear la carretera que
une marruecos con mauritania las
negociaciones políticas supervisadas por
la onu siguen estancadas a pesar del
anuncio de eeuu la organización no ha
cambiado su posición sobre el sahara
occidental- de acuerdo con su resolución
el territorio está todavía en proceso de
descolonización